selbst ist seit heute im handel die
nachfrage ist groß meist waren die
korona test schon nach kurzer zeit
vergriffen
fragwürdige geschäfte mit der maske in
der union wächst die kritik an den
vermittlungs deals von abgeordneten
historische dialog zwischen den
religionen im irak trifft papst
franziskus das oberhaupt der schiiten
großajatollah ali sistani
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen an
diesem samstag bei den nachrichten die
vom sport kommen heute von zehn fonds
auch von mir einen schönen guten abend
kaum waren sie im angebot gingen siebeck
wenig zum bald hieß es ausverkauft die
rede ist von den neuen corona
selbsttests die es heute erstmals bei
einem großen discounter gab und auch die
hotlines waren angesichts der nachfrage
völlig überlastet es ist aber auch kein
wunder dass die tests so beliebt sind
denn anders als die schnelltests für
dieses geschultes personal braucht
können die selbst fest ohne
vorkenntnisse angewendet werden zu hause
mit einer probe aus dem vorderen
nasenbereich sowohl beim schnell als
auch beim selbsttest gilt ein positives
ergebnis muss durch einen pcr test
überprüft werden weil die meldung eines
positiven tests aber nicht
kontrollierbar ist wird hier an die
eigene verantwortung appelliert dominik
müller sl früh genug aufstehen musste
heute für einen der raren selbsttests
ergattern wollte nun erleichterung
wenn sie in die schule gehen und was
irgendwie ein schnupfen haben wenn wir
mal zu gucken ist was oder es nichts es
beruhigt etwa um kurz vor acht eine
lange schlange vor dieser aldi filiale
in stuttgart viele hatten das nachsehen
die wenigen tests waren nach ein paar
minuten verärgerung bei manchen kunden
ab dann gab es nur noch gutscheine für
tests und ein einlösbar
doch wie hier in köln griffen auch da
viele zu die sehnsucht nach mehr
sicherheit und normalität ist groß doch
mal wieder meine mutter besuchen die
alleine lebt dies 80
und dann macht schnellen test und dann
kann ich dann auch wirklich noch mal
hinfahren dass ich dann eben welche habe
wenn ich ins restaurant will oder wenn
ich auch mal eine hotelübernachtung
haben möchte dann habe ich sie weil wenn
das alles freigegeben wird dann sind die
schlangen hier 300 meter lang
das versprechen auf mehr freiheit doch
was wenn der selbsttest kona anzeigt und
man in quarantäne muss beziehungsweise
zum arzt und keine offizielle stelle das
ergebnis mit bekommt dann ist bei den
selbsttests plötzlich viel
eigenverantwortung gefragt ich würde
wahrscheinlich beim arzt anrufen und
fragen was zu tun ist wenn mir sicher
dass es nicht alle tun würden
also ich würde mir das wünschen sozialer
machen der ansturm heute auf jeden fall
riesig
lidl startete mittlerweile online den
verkauf doch schnell waren die server
überlastet in den nächsten tagen wollen
weitere supermarkt und drogerieketten
nachziehen das angebot heute war viel zu
klein
in der union wächst die empörung über
parteikollegen die mit der beschaffung
von corona masken ein geschäft gemacht
haben
eine woche vor den wahlen in zwei
westlichen land tagen ein politisches
fiasko für die cdu
die baden- württembergische
spitzenkandidat in eisenmann legte ihrem
parteifreund löbel den rücktritt nahe
er hatte nach eigener aussage für die
vermittlung von masken rund eine
viertelmillion an provisionen kassiert
mathis feldhoff der neueste masken deal
erscheint besonders skurril nikolas
löbel cdu-abgeordneter wartet seinen
guten china kontakten zu einem kollegen
abgeordneter des volkskongresses und
zufällig masken lieferant
vor zehn tagen georg nüßlein csu er
kassierte 660.000 euro
der staatsanwalt ermittelt löbel bekam
rund 250.000 er verteidigt seinen deal
als privat nach einem wutausbruch
schreiben fraktionschef brinkhaus und
vize dobrindt das beziehen von
geldleistungen für die vermittlung von
medizinischer schutzausrüstung stößt auf
unser vollkommenes unverständnis bei der
cdu mitten im wahlkampf ist man
stinksauer wenn das mandat dafür
eingesetzt wurde
diese diesen verkauf diese vermittlung
zu bewerkstelligen dann ist auch der
rücktritt umgehend erforderlich möchte
ich in aller offenheit sagen das passt
nicht in unsere partei
das ist unanständig ich will es nicht
noch härter formulieren ich bin da
wirklich erzürnt und auch der
koalitionspartner urteilt scharf gerade
in einer zeit in der es so auf vertrauen
ankommt ist es gift wenn der eindruck
entsteht hier herrschen
vetternwirtschaft und raffgier das
problem in diesen beiden fällen ist dass
die beiden mit hohem sehr hohen beträgen
davon persönlich profitiert haben und
das erweckt den anschein dass politiker
insgesamt käuflich sind die masken erst
waren sie umstritten dann waren sie
knapp inzwischen werden einzelne deals
zu echten politkrimi und dann schauen
wir auf die aktuellen corona zahlen das
robert koch institut meldet neun 1557
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages das
sind 205 weniger als vergangenen samstag
300 menschen starben
die positiv auf das virus getestet
wurden die sieben tage incidents liegt
bei 65,6 bei denen zu hause lebenden
pflegebedürftigen menschen über 80 gibt
es ein schwerwiegendes problem
dort erreicht sie oft der
überlebenswichtige impfstoff nicht und
er wegen sims zentrum ist für viele
nicht zu schaffen
deutschlandweit betrifft das rund
400.000 menschen
deshalb sollen ärztinnen und ärzte nun
hausbesuche machen um auch diejenigen
impfen zu können
nicht mobil sind marion geiger so ich
habe die verzögerung auf diesen moment
hat hausarzt günter gerhardt lange
gewartet endlich hat der impfstoff
bekommen für die menschen die nicht ins
impfzentrum können
seine patientin veronika klingelschmitt
ist 80 jahre alt bettlägerig und
brauchten impfschutz dringend sie sich
anstecken würde
das ging nicht gut aus und wir haben ja
auch etwas dafür würde ich sage kämpft
aber verhandelt und geredet und ich bin
froh dass es jetzt soweit ist impfen zu
hause durch den hausarzt in rheinland
pfalz wird es seit dieser woche erprobt
dr gerhard ist teil eines pilotprojekts
bewährt es sich könnte ab mitte märz im
ganzen bundesland bei hausbesuchen
geimpft werden
wir erwarten bis ende april allen 20.000
bettlägerigen über 80 jährigen einen
impf angebot machen zu können
wen er zu hause impft entscheide dr
gerhard selbst carolina phrase ist 92 im
impfzentrum hätte sie angst ihrem
hausarzt aber vertraut sie die stiftung
patientenschutz mahnt an viel mehr
menschen in ihrer häuslichen umgebung zu
impfen
sowohl bund als auch die länder haben
diejenigen die zu hause leben müssen
vollkommen aus dem blick verloren
zwar haben wir jetzt impfzentren wir
haben auf suchen.de angebote in
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen aber
vergessen wir nicht 400.000 menschen
sind im obi leben zu hause und die
müssen dringend versorgt werden
impfen daheim für pflegebedürftige und
ihre familien ist es eine große
erleichterung in leipzig haben hunderte
menschen mit autokorsos gegen die krone
politik der regierung protestiert
rund 350 fahrzeuge waren beteiligt
deutlich weniger als erwartet
ein grund war der gegenprotest unter dem
motto querdenken ausbremsen
etwa 1000 demonstrierenden versammelten
sich mit fahr und motorrädern im
stadtgebiet
die polizei war mit einem großaufgebot
im
einsatz in brasilien jagt ein trauriger
rekord den anderen
täglich sterben inzwischen fast 2000
menschen und experten haben sorge dass
dort immer neue virusvarianten entstehen
die sich dann wieder weltweit verbreiten
trotzdem lehnt präsident szenario weiter
ausgangs beschränkungen und impfungen ab
aus rio de janeiro christoph reckert
die bilder wirken altbekannt doch die
vorzeichen haben sich geändert
eine neue corona welle überrollt
brasilien mit einer wucht die
einzigartig ist
mehr tote mehr infizierte denn je und
das erstmals nicht nur an brennpunkten
sondern im ganzen land die zahl der
patienten hat für einen tsunami schwerer
fälle gesorgt da jetzt die
brasilianischen krankenhäuser
überschwemmt und mehr als 19 von 27
provinzhauptstädten in einem kritischen
zustand befördert hat die brasilianische
virusvariante p1 ist dabei auf dem
vormarsch sie ist ansteckender wohl auch
für menschen die schon einmal corona
hatten wenn brasilien das virus nicht
unter kontrolle bekommt wird es weiter
mutieren mit potenziell verheerenden
folgen für die ganze welt warnt einer
der einflussreichsten mediziner
lateinamerikas mit diesen neuen
varianten kann es passieren dass zwar
die ganze welt auch brasilien gegen
bisherige virusstämme geimpft sein mag
doch sollten die neuen varianten dagegen
resistent sein werden sie sich trotzdem
verbreiten
deshalb habe ich brasilien auch schon
als das größte freiluft labor der welt
für die verbreitung von kogit bezeichnet
präsident von zonare aber ignoriert
weiter die warnungen der wissenschaft
stattdessen warnt er vor angeblichen
gefahren des masken tragens und lehnt
einen lock down ab genug mit dem
gejammer und dem mini me wie lange
wollen wir noch rumheulen trotz des
widerstands des präsidenten haben sich
jetzt einige bundesstaaten im alleingang
für einzelne lockdown maßnahmen
entschieden
brasilien taumelt weiter ohne
gesamtkonzept durch eine beispiellose
krise die immer mehr menschen tötet und
der welt neue gefährlichere
virusvarianten bescheren können
in den usa hat präsident biden einen
wichtigen etappensieg errungen
nach langer debatte billigte der senat
das 1,9 billionen dollar schwere corona
hilfspaket damit sollen die wirtschaft
wieder angekurbelt und staatliche
hilfszahlungen finanziert werden
nun muss noch das repräsentantenhaus
zustimmen
jetzt zu außergewöhnlichen begegnungen
im irak herbst franziskus ist am zweiten
tag seiner reise mit dem höchsten
schiitischen geistlichen des landes
zusammengekommen
großayatollah sistani beide betonten die
friedliche koexistenz der religionen
außerdem traf der papst weitere
religiöse oberhäupter in der
symbolträchtigen statur
andreas postel berichtet vom
historischen brückenschlag zwischen
katholischer kirche und schiitischen
islam warten in der wüste auf papst
franziskus und das interreligiöse
treffen am tag zwei seiner pilgerreise
in den irak die unter strengsten
sicherheitsauflagen stattfindet habs
franziskus erreicht die ebene von uhr in
gepanzerte limousine
die erwartungen sind hoch ohne zweifel
ist dieses treffen von sehr grosser
tragweite
wir kehren zu unseren moralischen und
spirituellen wurzeln zurück die alle
menschen miteinander teilen egal welcher
religion sie angehören
die antike stadt uhr gilt laut
biblischer überlieferung als
geburtsstätte abrahams des stammvaters
von juden christen und muslimen
abraham habe in den gleichen himmel
geschaut dieselben sterne gesehen so
franziskus abraham verbinde die
gläubigen frieden erfordert weder sieger
noch besiegte sondern brüder und
schwestern die trotz der
missverständnisse und wunden der
vergangenheit den weg vom konflikt zur
einheit gehen
begonnen hat der tag in nadschaf dieser
heiligen stadt der schiiten und der mit
spannung erwarteten begegnung zwischen
papst franziskus und großajatollah ali
al sistani das als privat deklarierte
gespräch am haus des obersten führers
des irak dauerte 40 minuten allein dass
es stattfindet ist eine kleine sensation
die irakische regierung hat den sechsten
märz heute zum nationalen festtag
erklärt als tag der toleranz und
koexistenz und mit auf dieser reise ist
jürgen erbacher für uns irgendwo rum ist
diese reise und das gespräch mit dem
obersten schiiten als ist sensationell
was will papst franziskus erreichen
pabst franziskus will im interreligiösen
dialog vorankommen weil er überzeugt ist
die religionen müssen zur bewältigung
der krisen vor denen der die welt steht
mitte beitragen vor zwei jahren hat er
ein dokument unterzeichnet mit einem
hochrangigen sunnitischen geistlichen in
abu dhabi darin verurteilen sie gewalt
im namen der religion und verpflichten
die religionen auf versöhnung und
frieden der besuch heute bei
großayatollah sistani war ein erster
schritt um auch die schiiten mit ins
boot zu holen
also diese zweite große strömung im
islam zu einer gemeinsamen erklärung hat
es heute noch nicht gereicht im vorfeld
war darüber spekuliert worden
aber aus vatikanischen kreisen ist zu
hören dass ein erster hoffnungsvoller
schritt gemacht ist einen kleinen
wermutstropfen gibt es dann doch an
diesem tag beim interreligiösen gebet in
uhr wo man abraham dem stammvater der
christen der juden und der muslime
gedacht hat fehlten die juden und das
zeigt wenn papst franziskus mit dem
dialog der religionen und vorankommen
will hat er noch ein großes stück arbeit
vor sich
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung jürgen
erbacher wie schon erwähnt wird am
kommenden sonntag in zwei bundesländern
gewählt in baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz weitere vier
landtagswahlen und die bundestagswahl
folgen noch in diesem chor ohne ja immer
wichtiger wird dabei die briefwahl bis
zur hälfte aller stimmen könnten so
abgegeben werden christopher heinze
berichtet es ist in diesen tagen
ziemlich viel los im briefwahlbüro der
rheinland pfälzischen landeshauptstadt
mainz alles natürlich corona konform
seit anfang februar können hier
unterlagen beantragt und abgeholt werden
einige stimmen gleich direkt vor ort ab
vorbei und gibt die stimme ab und ist
jetzt gut um die kontakte möglichst
einzuschränken jetzt gerade wegen corona
pro tag bearbeiten sie derzeit bis zu
1000 anträge allein hier in mainz ein
rekord aufkommen stimmten bei der
rheinland pfälzischen landtagswahl 2016
insgesamt 30 prozent per briefwahl ab
hat stand heute schon jeder zweite
wahlberechtigte briefwahl beantragt und
in der verbleibenden woche kommen
voraussichtlich noch viele hinzu wir
haben kontinuierlich anwachsen der
briefwahlbeteiligung erlebt im prinzip
bei allen wahlen bei der europa- und
kommunalwahlen rheinland pfalz hatten
wir zuletzt ein anteil von rund 50
prozent bei der briefwahl insofern sieht
man dass sich immer mehr wählerinnen und
wähler für diesen weg entscheiden auch
ganz losgelöst von corona ob einzelne
parteien von einem hohen briefaufkommen
profitieren lässt sich laut experten
kaum sagen
insgesamt kann man sagen dass die
mobilisierung auch über die briefwähler
interpretierbar ist wer hohe briefwahl
anteile also verzeichnet kann auch davon
ausgehen dass die wahlbeteiligung
insgesamt hoch sein wird
die lag 2016 bei gut 70 prozent
noch bis freitag können
briefwahlunterlagen beantragt werden mit
einem ärztlichen attest sogar noch am
wahltag und nun zu den erfolgen der
deutschen im wintersport sind ja mit
zwei medaillen am vorletzten
wettkampftag bei den nordischen
ski-weltmeisterschaften in oberstdorf
erst hatten die kombinierer fabian
rießle und eric frenzel für bronze im
team sprint gesorgt dann triumphierten
die deutschen skispringer im team
gold für deutschlands skispringer im
teamspringen in einem packenden
wettbewerb liefern sich deutschland
österreich polen und japan ein enges
rennen bis zum schluss zur halbzeit dann
markus eisenbichler 135 meter liegt
deutschland noch mit 3,7 punkten vorn
dann die letzten springer der
abschließenden gruppe im zweiten
durchgang polen führt zu diesem
zeitpunkt mit einem punkt dann der
österreicher kraft österreich geht in
führung doch dann kommt karl geiger 136
metern gold für deutschland im
teamwettbewerb vor österreich und polen
zwei männer im schnee am ende über
glücklich über bronze
da war dass wir das deutsche kombinierer
duo im team-sprint eric frenzel und zwar
wären riesling nicht gut ausgesehen
frenzel mit einer guten leistung und 132
meter
doch dann patrice 123 meter nur rang
vier nach dem springen
und doch wurden die beiden nach einer
tollen kämpferischen leistung in der
loipe noch große weltmeister wird
österreich von mobbing
jubeln durfte außerdem race vorderen
ramona hofmeister beim weltcup in rogla
slowenien die 24 jährige aus
bischofswiesen besiegte im
parallel-riesenslalom sofia nadir china
aus russland damit hat hochmeister gute
chancen auf den erneuten gewinn des
gesamtweltcups in zwei wochen mehr
wintersportler nachher im aktuellen
sportstudio mit dunja hayali außerdem
alles zur bundesliga mit dem abendspiel
bayern münchen gegen borussia dortmund
ab 23 uhr
und zumindest bis zum ende des topspiels
haben wir einen neuen tabellenführer rb
leipzig hatte im kampf um die
tabellenspitze vorgelegt mit einem 13 0
sieg in freiburg
außerdem gewann leverkusen in gladbach
und hoffenheim überraschte zu hause
gegen den vfl wolfsburg
wichtige punkte im abstiegskampf für
hertha bsc gegen augsburg frankfurt und
stuttgart trennten sich 1 1
unentschieden
dazu noch die nullnummer von gestern
abend zwischen schalke und mainz in der
tabelle jetzt leipzig mit einem punkt
vor den bayern wolfsburg trotz der
niederlage auf 3 leverkusen und dortmund
auf den weiteren europapokal plätzen und
sogar wieder dran an der champions
league gladbach mit der 5
lage in folge auf platz zehn die hertha
verschafft sich etwas luft nach unten
mainz auf dem relegationsplatz und
schalke bleibt mit acht punkten
rückstand auf den relegationsplatz
letzter ja und das war s das war als
phädra danke flynn wieder erwartet uns
heute eine eisige nacht wo morgen die
sonne scheint das erfahren sie gleich
beim wetter mit es sind elli das war es
von uns danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
das heute journal mit claus kleber wie
meistens am samstag erst um drei viertel
elf wir sagen tschüss und wünschen noch
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter kaltluft ist
erneut ein thema und sie erreichte uns
von norden her und vor allem den norden
deutschlands dann am späten nachmittag
und abend und es ist etwas regen dabei
ansonsten haben wir mit viel
sonnenschein zu tun denn das hoch jedes
lässt sich noch nicht vertreiben
schauen wir in die nacht da gibt es
viele wolken im norden deutschlands
ansonsten klart es größtenteils auf ganz
im nordwesten richtung emsland da bildet
sich dann nebel
die temperaturen sinken auf minus ein
bis minus 7 grad teils bis minus neun im
südosten frostfrei mit plus 2 grad
bleibt es an der ostsee morgen an viel
sonnenschein in der mitte und nach süden
hin nach norden hin ist es deutlich
dichter bewölkt und da kommt eben spät
nachmittags abends dann regen auf und
der geht dann in der darauf folgenden
nacht in schnee über ja und der wind der
wtf strom aus westlichen richtungen die
temperaturen erreichten maximalwerte von
drei bis elf grad ja und die nächsten
tage gehen im großen ganzen ruhig weiter
mit etwas regen zb am montag im westen
und 3 bis 10 grad ein schöner abend